I don't know Halloween is just like a
weird holiday to be dressing up as
anybody else's cold you say the same
thing about any costume are you gonna
tell a six-year-old girl she can't dress
up like a pirate because she doesn't
know the history of pirates like that's
[Music]
we're all technically white you're from
England if you're from Australia if
you're from wherever South Africa you
know we all have these crazy places we
come from and these people were around
and we get those ideas from those people
but that doesn't mean us as a whole have
no culture but as a white person it's
not really a culture you can have
culture like I'm hella Irish obviously
and that's a culture but that just being
white is not a it's it's not a culture I
can't relate to you just because you're
white I think you could say that for any
ethnicity though if we were all black
could I relate to you guys if just
because of the color of our skin yes
because they go through some very
similar experiences like they'll get
discriminated against and you're not
getting discriminated against because of
your skin color they can both relate to
that but I also feel like with culture
we branch out we try different things we
want to do different things so maybe
we've lost a little bit of our culture
maybe we're creating a new culture
we can explain it okay reverse racism is
like someone being racist against you
because you were white like do you
believe that someone can be racist
against a white person yes I grew up
where it was completely like Hispanic
culture I was constantly made fun of
because I was white Oh white people
can't dance white people look stupid
whatever they shouldn't say white people
can't dance but I think they can I just
putting that out there but I like being
honest though like they would say those
mean things to me and more hurtful
things than that it's like a hard pill
to swallow because if I turned around
said black people can't dance I'd get
hell for that but then if someone says
the same words to me it's somehow okay
because you have to look at the
difference of it though and I relate to
you I grew up with all Latino or black
friends I had very few white friends and
you know I got made fun of for being
like the white girl I was green God and
I didn't take offense to it because the
huge part about racism is that there's
hate and oppression behind it and as a
white person in America I do not feel
oppressed and I definitely think that we
should take the log out of our own eyes
before worrying about the sawdust and
other people's like I totally agree with
that but there is sawdust so that's kind
of what I'm saying for me I feel like
anything we do can come out racist to
any other type race where the same time
if they say something mean or racist to
us that we feel is racist it's brushed
off I might think of the word racism I
think more towards oppression so that's
why I'm in the disagree like I'll deal
if someone just being mean to me but
what
I think it's important to focus on race
in order to bring us together there is a
race issue in America and if we just
avoid it all together and pretend like
it's not happening nothing's going to
change in my opinion I kind of was
thinking about the question differently
because if all I'm thinking about when I
meet someone is oh I'm Way and she's not
white and I'm Way and she's not white
like that for me that's like what
focusing on races yeah we're never gonna
be happy unless we just like all work
together just like treat each other like
each other you know like there is no
race yeah and that sounds great but it's
like we're not there we're not there I
feel like people who have that
perspective might also say like oh I
don't see color try not you know try to
have that attitude I don't think that
helps anybody I think we need to like to
respect each other's backgrounds and
like that is only gonna happen if we do
see color we do like appreciate
everybody's differences
[Music]
yeah I think cultural appropriation is
very well you see all the time like
Coachella you know we're in LA and you
see people in the Native American
headdresses without knowing how
important that is to native people yeah
exactly I think there's a difference
between respecting the culture and
completely disrespecting the culture but
then also if you want to dress up and
Halloween like a Geisha because you like
the costume you think it's a beautiful
costume that I wouldn't say is I
wouldn't do that
I think if you're gonna go and dress up
as a geisha without knowing the
importance of it and just being like
well this is cute like I'm gonna put
this on and also even if you did know
the importance and you're like I don't
know Halloween is just like a weird
holiday to be dressing up as anybody
else's cold you can say the same thing
about any costume are you gonna tell a
six-year-old girl that she can't dress
up like a pirate because she doesn't
know the history of pirates like that's
very different so it's just like that's
very different those are those are
children
I think because I think wearing that
thing at Coachella like I feel like I
would see that is that person mocking
someone well even if they don't
intentionally mean it it's still
offensive
the only reason I'm at somewhat disagree
is because a lot of my favorite rappers
use it frequently if I'm listening to my
favorite childish gambino song which it
drops it like a hundred times it's like
I'm not sitting there thinking all these
horrible things about black people and
I'm like it's just in the song and when
I'm singing it comes out there's like
two different forms of the word there
ends with an ER and with an A and like
with my friends they're like oh you can
say it with it's a like that won't hurt
my feelings but also like even when I'm
in the car by myself like I still feel
like it's not my place maybe I'll like
whisper it like with an A at the end you
know like if I'm by myself but like I
know the respect for other people I just
think it's more appropriate not to say
it at all do you guys think rappers
should stop putting it in their songs I
feel like everything it's wrong though I
don't think it's wrong because the
history of the n-word come you know
slave owners would call black people as
the n-word with the hard are at the end
if black people want to take that word
and claim it as their own and claim that
that painful history and like be like f
you like I'm gonna claim this word I
think they should be allowed to do that
I don't think as a white person I have
that right to take a word that was
derogatory towards them they should 100%
have the right to do that do you think
it's okay for a white person to sing the
song see that's where more like all on
the fence it's like I feel like it's
just it's a word used as like my friend
basically and like just like she said if
they want to take that back from it's
horrible origins then I'm totally fine
with that but as a white person you
can't say that word without feeling a
certain way if you if they didn't put it
in their songs you wouldn't say it right
no so are they causing people just say
that word more often because she
wouldn't say it it's not white people's
place to tell them what they can and
cannot use so
[Music]
three-two-one it's so sad to say because
I never say it out loud but it's the
truth
is like getting pulled over by the
police I always feel like I have a
little bit of a one-up because I'm white
because I'm a woman and I feel so bad
that that's the truth
but this is a real thing and it's
unfortunate for me as an individual I
feel like I'm not privileged sure like
white people background came from like
being higher up on the scale but I've
gone through really hard things before
you know I don't feel like I'm superior
for other people so as an individual I
don't feel like I'm privileged
I think privileged I guess I don't
really think that I'm above other people
I just think that naturally I'm treated
different yeah it's like perception it's
just perception it's yeah I think that's
a huge misconception I have privilege
that I didn't ask for it
it's just society sees me as like the
standard for whatever reason and because
of that I get treated differently and
why privilege you know like you said
it's not about what you've gone through
or what you experienced it's a hundred
percent how the world sees me
[Music]
I don't I almost went there too it's
like actually guiltily like I am like
happy that I'm not oppressed but I'm not
proud of like things people have done in
the past when I when I think of being
proud of something I think of something
I worked for or that uh yeah I had to
get I had to do nothing to be white
absolutely nothing and nothing was taken
from me because I was white it's like
saying I'm a proud white person is a
completely different saying than saying
I'm a proud black person because when
you hear I'm a proud black person I
think empowerment I think strength
I think courage I think you know all
these amazing things that the black
community has done and accomplished
throughout the years but then when you
say I am a strong or I'm a proud white
person already there's so much like hate
involved in that thing about that is
like like how you said someone who says
I'm proud to be black
that's empowerment why aren't I allowed
to be proud to be white what makes it
proud of just your skin color because
yes that is wrong so usually I can't be
proud to be white because I don't have a
culture no I you that's not what I'm
saying they said when white people say
they're proud to be white a lot of times
at least in my opinion they're just
they're talking about their skin color
that they're not a different race I
think that's wrong yeah but as like we
were talking about as a proud black
person they've been oppressed that a lot
of their culture was stolen from them
and a lot of reasons that I don't like
proud to be white is because it hasn't
the the Nazis used it the the KKK used
it I don't want to be associated with
any of those things so I'm just gonna
completely stay away from that sure I'm
not proud of like what my culture is
done but at the same time like I would
not want to be anything else if I had to
choose another race I don't know what I
would be I'm okay with where I am even
though I'm getting backlash about being
white hey guys this is John and I'm Erin
thank you so much for watching this
episode of spectrum we hope you enjoyed
the discussion let us know what you
thought in the comments below and if
you'd like to watch more of our videos
click here to subscribe and we'll see
you next time